this video shows you how to create a  quick labs account you can skip this  section if you've already created a  quick labs account if you do not have a  quick labs account you can create one  now if you already have a quick labs  account you can skip this section and go  directly to the section about redeeming  credits in a web browser navigate to  Google quick labs comm on the quick labs  home page click join click join with  email enter your first and last name and  your email address specify the same  email address that you use for your  Coursera account for company name  specify your institution's name or none  enter a password enable the opt-in box  to receive additional quick labs credits  after you complete the cloud  architecture quest enable the I'm not a  robot CAPTCHA and click create a new  account check your email account for an  account confirmation email from quick  labs click the link in the email to  confirm your account